[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà vous pouvez me rappeler comme ça
quand votre petit il est parti ne
traitez pas de poule
c'est une petite poule vont très bien à
les y aller tout de suite une question
bonjour je m'appelle margot dans votre
équipe il ya un objet d un style de jeu
une grenade et une seule qui dansent
tout le temps donc je voulais savoir
c'est quoi exactement votre critère de
recrutement
on aimerait bien savoir
c'est une très bonne question chère
margot et bien sachez que cyril recrute
ses chroniqueurs sur un seul critère
l'excellence tu as comme il le dit si
bien lui même est très très très heureux
de vous retrouver
sachez que toutes les personnes qui sont
là ne sont pas en échec scolaire qu'on
apprendra encore des choses dans cette
émission et on est heureux que vous
soyez aussi nombreux à nous regarder
bon d'accord c'est pas le seul critère
dont ce qui compte c'est surtout le
travail est bien préparé des émissions
thierry moreau par exemple est
infaillible il connaît tous nos invités
par coeur comme ici yoann frégé bon
d'accueillir le gagnant de l'année
dernière 2 au vote qui était avec nous
c'est johan frégère police locale
[Applaudissements]
tia hellebaut belge en rien réussi le
pire
voilà ça c'est qu'il aura reconnu le
yuan sur les images on reconnaît pas
parce qu'on voit pas oui ça il va vivre
le temps quand il prépare l'émission
s'était parqué sur ses fiches
lorient l1 gagnant de la saison 2 de the
voice qui nous a fait un superbe cadeau
pour la pub en improvisant une chanson
ça vous l'avez pas eu donc je voulais
vous le faire partager
[Musique]
celle là
il a une voix exceptionnelle c'est un
garçon que j'adore ça evans français qui
chantent oui mais ils connaissent leur
annonce qu'ils connaissent sur rien et
j'appelle les cd r c'est pour ça qu'on
est nombreux à nous sommes
complémentaires il fait ça que chacun
son utilité dans l'équipe
enora par exemple son rôle c'est de
lancer des applaudissements c'est pas
gentil de se moquer alors ok n'ai pas eu
l'air ridicule pour rien on va lancer
dès aujourd'hui le premier produit
dérivé de touche pas à mon poste la
larme de bagnols enora malagré l'afrique
mais on rigole mais c'était difficile et
dans le bon tempo peut pas que pour une
ora vous allez voir pour lancer à pleaux
c'est compliqué je vous ai fait une
petite compil à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr nos quatre leaders à nous
rejoindre également
et puis qui viendra nous rejoindre dans
un instauré jonathan lambert
[Musique]
on accueille tout de suite laurence
pieau est une enfant qui s'appelle soi
voire lise majorité
ouais
[Applaudissements]
mais la tristesse je sentais un peu seul
banquier n'aura hélas pour lancer les
applaudissements mais pas que vous avez
montré il ya quelques semaines les
réactions d'isabelle morini-bosc
lorsqu'elle regarde et jimmy foxtrot
si vous avez oublié un petit rappel
[Musique]
couturier
tu ne l'as pas céder à la commune à
l'aller formidable bras il faut croire
que jamie foxx faute à un pouvoir
hypnotique
car la semaine dernière c'est nora qui
était envoûté bonsoir c'est un animateur
télé car c'est un animateur radio
rotative ces petits bateaux
quand états américains
allez
ce personnage on vit le personnage
j'aimais les images j'ai mieux que ça a
souhaité lundi dernier quand thierry un
jouet un sketch devant gad elmaleh ou là
alors je sais pas si thierry était
nerveux mais elle
alors pour ceux qui aimer l'école des
fans voici les parents du petit
itinéraire qui vivent au pour leur
champion vous allez voir c'est mignon
mais heureusement kenora c'était bien
laver les dents je te dis d éclater et d
éclater la veille de sa communion j'ai
attrapé mon fils
wesley snipes wesley kevin smith
mais vers les 1 tonne dans le tarn
son père porte à communion il mate
éclaté tu sais ce que ça veut dire ou
pas
j'ai loué le stade de france j'ai mal
invité un présentateur cyril hanouna
venir pour le stade de france
mais combien il va dépenser papa combien
combien allait venir à tout le monde
combien papa il a dépensé
bravo elle vit le cnpa le camarade le
gentil avec vous sachez pour les sachets
pour info qu'avec toutes les dents des
doigts on peut faire trois baies noires
non mais c'est le mur de berlin ça vous
va très bien on pas du tout est arrêté
en fait vous êtes la fille de jean marc
morandini vous
[Applaudissements]
c'est la maison témoin jamila c'est la
maison témoin je choisis les dents chez
elle avec du homard qui s'échangent des
dents tu dois cela je l'avais pas ça va
aussi à risque ou pas trop de joueurs
j'ai des dents pourries à loisir et non
bon fond ici bah ouais c'est pas une
tente dans le même sens pas se mentir
menora c'est pas que ça c'est aussi la
bonne humeur je voulais montrer la
semaine dernière elle un nouveau jeu le
pétage de tapant est bien avec son
compagnon bénéfique christophe la touffe
elle rit ça
[Applaudissements]
oh
c'est lyon bruno je sais que vous adorez
les questions 4/3 mont-bruno mais je ne
veux pas je sais que vous avez le
théâtre et je veux pas que vous preniez
de risque ah oui d'accord il ya
quelqu'un at il alors pour vous aider
20h12 exactement ouais voilà donc je
sais que je vous savez que je suis un
alésien
voilà évidemment mais je voudrais
rappeler qu'il est au théâtre bien sûr
on va continuer la maison je sais que
vous vouliez d'avoir longtemps encore
parce que j'aimerais bien voir la fin
quand mais combien de temps je ne sais
pas ça dépend des actions six minutes 5
6 me allez allez allez
[Applaudissements]
c'est beau mais qui j'attends l'ailé de
la haye où aller au delà
bon alors vous voulez duo alors c'est
idiot le pétage de la poste mais c'est
rigolo
donc de ce côté là on crie dans les
oreilles on va voir de l'openair il
s'occupe le temps de la pub
ce serait mon crayon
[Rires]
[Musique]
quoi
l'imprimante et visiter son site ici
la pression non mais non
saleh
m
[Musique]
je
regardez quel gamin timide doigt coincé
ça chauffe qu'est ce qu'il faut retenir
de cette vidéo un que valérie bénaïm
devrait avoir un ophtalmo le cnt devant
elle elle n'a pas vu et que deux
jean-michel fait n'importe quoi et bat
pas vraiment à merci jean mich nicht a
fait ça c'est parce qu'il avait une idée
en tête
oui d'après lui son stylo dans une
bouteille on peut faire quelque chose
enfin le mieux c'est qu'il vous explique
sa théorie de battles qui l'avait marqué
sans il recentre à la mine
[Musique]
elle est pas mauvais l'afrique au ciel
[Applaudissements]
les avait outré c'est ça la question
constante chaque soir comment il pense
qu'il serait bien de faire un saut
interdite sur les corps des danseurs
c'est pas vrai tu peux pas écrire que
cette partie du corps j'ai essayé mais
bon je vous rassure le baroudeur poivre
et sel ne fait pas que ça que si l'eau
ils s'en servent aussi pour répondre à
des questions essentielles
là
quelques jours
ah les huit ans d'âge mental jean michel
est resté très jeune dans sa tête mais
aussi dans son corps parce que vous le
savez vous pouvez le voir ce soir pour
notre séducteur a laissé pousser ses
poils ah oui exceptionnellement je vais
trahir un secret ils avaient peur que ça
ne vieillissent pour l'instant il va
trouver la parade des choses
exceptionnelles
j'ai les images de l'instant exact où il
a été touché par la grâce
tout de suite son conseil beauté
[Musique]
non je veux compléter les cheveux longs
blonds et papa tu fais plus vieux que
comme ça c'est petit
publié en revanche que les salaires
données
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'abord zone interdite je versais moi ce
que j'ai aimé c'est le moment où il dit
rien presque jamais assez on se dit il
pense à un truc intelligent je n'ai pas
fermé
[Rires]
rappel vol au dessus d'un nid de coucou
je vais montrer ce qu'il sait un petit
truc auquel on pense pas mais qui est
simple à réaliser chez soi aller mais
bon je vais pas caricaturer jean-michel
ne parle pas que de rasage de pubis non
heureusement il parle aussi brushing
s'il a une fille dans suivi un brushing
aussi parfait forcément fourbe
c'est une vraie surprise
médecin rocher avait sali passage il
passe à dix passaro chine et éthiques
[Musique]
tu pars d'une discussion s'est tout de
suite fonctionné tout n'est là je me
désolidarise sur ses terres mais
franchement tout ça ça a fini par
traumatisé son voisin thierry parce que
même quand jean-michel étape sans
permission
non je regardais le plus de là
[Musique]
j'ai gardé un goût amer ce mec est un
vice line probe rejoint michel mr
rock'n'beat non là il comme ton copain
copain indiqué michel mr il a partout ça
c'est sûr
[Musique]
l'accusé thierry non encore une fois
dans cette émission la seule personne
valable c'est cyril merci jean c'est pas
une surprise mais siri est au dessus de
nous tous ses vols avec les aigles
mais non j'ai pas peur de le dire si rim
marquera la télé française car c'est le
seul capable de dire à 19h30 sur une
chaîne nationale
mais moi je sortais des choses de mon
slip on s'en prend plein la gueule
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dis moi tu content mais je crois que
c'est un acte qui est fait naturellement
ces questions bonjour je m'appelle
marvin j'ai entendu dire que pour
insulter cyril hanouna philippe bouvard
l'avait traité de vendeurs d'épinards
c'est quoi cette insulte ilham autant
les épinards bouvard je peux lui en foot
dans le cul
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]